This is like the content. If you want if you want to join the
discord and you don't want to participate in the content, uh
I don't know why you don't want to laughing in the background
until Cherry left and now I'm suddenly not
Somebody laughing in the background, right? I don't need somebody
laughing in the background. There's other people offering to
do it. You asked me to come join this Discord so you could be
on the stream and you don't actually
want to participate for some arbitrary reason that you've not
explained. Uh the reason is you asked us to come join this discord,
right? And then you don't want to participate. You don't want
to like be a part of this. Yes, I am participating. I'm just
not reading the furry ERP out
message.
I don't know.
Oh, uh Kelly wants us to switch to the other Discord, I think.
Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Uh, are we going to do the reading now? Yeah, let's read
this last set of DMs here. I want to go to TwitchCon with you
still. Okay. Oh, it's lost.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
you seem to want to hook up at TwitchCon. Is this the case or
not? I wouldn't be opposed.
So want an IRL relationship with me but not commit it. Oo
is that crying? Oo
and you you don't want to have RL stuff with anyone else, right?
Yes.
Smacks your head.
That's the same as being in a committed relationship. You dingus.
God. I Good stuff. Oh, hold on.
Why are you like this?
Hold on for that. Perfect. Okay, this is hilarious. I want to
go to TwitchCon with you still. You seem to want to hook up at
TwitchCon. Is this the case or not?
Sherlock Holmes over here on the left side. God damn. What a
guy. What? Like Alexa responding to you or something. Which is
witch, by the way. I have no clue.
I am the I'm Lyric,
which is the girl who pays him $800 cuz like he's a
And is that the gray or the blue bubble?
It's a The gray bubble is Lyric and it's he he's a fan. But um
the blue is Lyric. The gray is Thor, right? Was
that maybe I'm Hold on. Am I just not understanding at all?
Maybe I don't remember. I I was reading the right messages. I
know that. I just don't remember the colors. Yeah, honestly,
the confusion makes it more funny at all.
This is the cringiest thing that's been read since uh um
Yeah, never mind.
Where's So
conversations, donations? We're all thinking it.
Okay. I just want to make sure there aren't more.
dude. Oh my god. I think they are a furry.
Yeah, Thor is Wait, did you not know that Thor was a furry when
you met him? You didn't know that ferret
fundraising for like my friend's um charity. He is a gay furry.
He is a gay furry. He is a gay furry. But has he ever got does
he have a fursuit? Unless I see this. He's got a persona. He's
got a persona. His p his person he's uh in a committed relationship
with is like openly a furry. He is a furry 100%. He just doesn't
like like making it open because he gets to him on the internet.
Okay. I feel like calling someone that just has a persona but
never actually has a fursuit and goes up and dresses up to conventions
like a furry is kind of like calling someone that's like a VTuber
is a cosplayer. It doesn't really
unless you're being a furry. You're not a furry. Like the internet
does not count. No, I would say if you're performing like it's
not about it's not like calling them a cosplayer or something.
It's like uh it's right like if somebody engages in their interest
Jesus Christ Kelly if somebody engages in in furry play constantly
on the internet using like their persona I'm going to call them
a furry if they're turned on by thinking of themselves as an
anthropomorphic animal. Yeah, absolutely they're a furry. Yeah,
but that's not dedicated, bro. If you're not actually in the
furry super
not really a furry. That's just like lame. like commit and do
lots of furries are like that and just too poor to ever get the
fursuit. The fursuits are expensive. Also, you can just get like
the head and like the tail. Some people do that. You could also
make your own.
Learn how to sew. It means so much to you. I'm like, don't do
things halfass. Do it properly. I don't know why I'm going down
this line of conversation.
In any case, he is definitely a furry. And I'm guessing, hold
on. We'll just see. Maybe maybe there will be no um maybe there'll
be no furry stuff in here. I don't know. Okay. Should we How
should we do this? If If Kelly's here, can you just read with
Kelly so I can go back to um doing the thing that I'm doing?
Is Kelly going to read the other side? No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. You'll have to hire someone else. I'm
sorry. I cannot read any of this. I will puke.
I'm just going to laugh.
Okay. If Cherry doesn't want to do it though, like open the floor.
Who else would do this? It's very embarrassing.
Okay, you're a good sport. Did you Did you ask to join just to
just to laugh as we do this in real
partially and to like find out uh if this guy is actually like
a problem, but so far it's just been cringe. Oh, he's uh I mean
he's just like a narcissist weirdo. He's really like he's just
like a little bit more narcissistic than the average streamer,
right?
Like maybe a decent amount more narcissistic than the average
streamer. Average male streamer.
Sure.
He's like pretty bad. The Dr. K. Well, you you watched the Dr.
K. We covered that together, Kelly, didn't we? You're still in
J. Don't worry. Uh I think so. Wait, did we we did do some of
it and then I got annoyed cuz it was going on really long.
Okay, two two options here. The poll is going in the chat right
now. Oh, it's actually going to be a very short poll.
Conversations only first with Cherry.
Uh oh, hold on. How to proceed? Are you trying to kick me out?
Is this what you're doing a poll for? No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. You can say either way, Kelly. Um, I'm saying should
we do So, here they just have the conversations. Okay. And then,
but the rest of it would have like more stuff. Okay. I think
we're just going to go through the conversations. uh or do whole
story on Twitter. I'm I think I'm going to go to the website
right now
and run this poll for 30 seconds. Okay, I think I'm I'm probably
not even really thinking about doing the poll anymore. Honestly,
it's going to be the first one. Talking about narcissistic streamers
just reminded me of something I have to complain about. There
was a VTuber that complained that she couldn't go to TwitchCon
Europe on an emergency American passport.
Uhhuh. Let me find this tweet. I need a about this because isn't
it obvious that you can't travel for a fun event on an emergency
passport because it's not an
Like am I because every like reply to her tweet was like, "Oh
no, that's so sad."
Like not a single person pointed out she's a dumbass. And I was
like so tilted. Um I think you can get emergency passports for
business reasons,
but no, not for like going to TwitchCon. You can't like even
getting vis. So if you're a streamer, you can argue that TwitchCon
is a business thing and last minute like business bookings I
believe you can do emergency visas for.
Okay, so she was going
firstly she wasn't going from America. Secondly, um she was passing
through America which makes it more stupid. But secondly, I don't
think there's a single country in Europe that's going to accept
an emergency passport from America to go to an event. Like the
UK wouldn't allow that either, but they were acting like it was
like a political decision. And I'm like, no, I don't think anyone
can do this ever because it's not an emergency. Going to TwitchCon
is never an emergency. I'm like losing my mind.
Mhm. How did she get an emergency passport if she didn't have
an emergency? I think she applied for a normal one and then she
just didn't get the e emergency one in uh the real one in time.
So they gave her an emergency one and for some reason
somebody told her that it would be fine and then the Netherlands
was like no.
So I don't know.
Yeah, emergency passport is not what I was talking about. So
wait, what were you talking about about then? You can't Oh, no,
no, hold on. Other urgent travel. So, so if you need to travel
within 15 business days, so this would be the thing where I assume
you would go um like in Canada you need an expedited passport,
but um I think you can go and say I have a business
and a temporary one. Want to get it? Yeah, this is like a different
thing slightly. I think you would still be able to do it, but
I I just wouldn't feel bad for them if America didn't grant it,
right?
No, America granted the temporary passport, but the Nether she
passed through America to the Netherlands at TwitchCon, and the
Netherlands were like off cuz that's not an emergency. So, she
was passing through America to the Yeah. to Europe. But I don't
think any other European country would have accepted it either
because why would they? It's not an emergency. Like that's usually
for like you were you've lost your passport in another country
so you get a temporary passport to go home or like someone's
died or like some kind of dire medical emergency. I don't think
it's ever for like going to an event.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. I feel very I'm going to find this stupid tweet.
Yeah. We're going to we're going to do the conversations real
quick. Cherry has to go. She's got like very limited time to
be here tonight, Kelly. So we're going to do the conversations.
Sorry. I didn't mean to. No problem. No problem. No problem.
You didn't know. So, we're going to do the conversations and
then uh we can go through your tweet and stuff as well. Okay.
All right. All
So,
we're starting with the top of the conversations. We're actually
going to run through all of them again. Okay. Even if if we have
to.
You're gray. Oh, yes. Love bombing can be described as intense
displays of affection, declarations of love early in the relationship.
This rapid progression can be overwhelming and make it difficult
to see potential red flags. For abusers, love bombing can be
the first phase of the cycle of a cycle of abuse as often followed
by periods of devaluation and shame. The abuser may switch from
intense affection to criticism, control, and even emotional abuse.
From the abuser's perspective, love bombing is an investment.
It is a way to establish rapport and can later be cashed out
in the form of compliance, submission, and control.
Okay. The primary purpose of the article is to contrast Thor's
demeanor in the final conversation where he attempts to deny
any advances toward Lyric.
Okay. Final conversation will be after
As far as I knew, we were fooling around and seeing if we were
compatible. You've been pushing a lot for commitment kind of
uh for a commitment kind of thing. And Oh,
hold up. You've been pushing a lot for a commitment kind of thing,
but I have a lot of work stuff going on and not a lot of time.
I was just wondering if you want to hop into another call tonight.
And if not tonight, then sometime else. Oo.
Yes, every day. Like I said, silly. My stream starts in 20 minutes.
If you're awake, after it we should call. Oh,
But yes, my plan is to be on voice chat with you every day. A
woo. And you really make my life a ton better.
You make mine better, too. A woo.
You're so good to me. Oh, a woo.
Thor also expects the same dedication from Lyric, conveying his
emotional dependence on them. Of course. Thanks, babe. My pleasure.
these people are disgusting. Hey, Thor, how are you doing?
Not great. Surrounded by people. How are you?
Too gently.
Missed you today.
Been wonky lately. Aw, sleepy Thor. Wonky,
you're finally getting to bed at a reasonable hour. Even so,
I hope you're not feeling too bad. Do you feel
Uh, not ill. Just missing you and hoping you miss me.
Thor would show unconditional support for Lyric. This is a very
weird statement for a 31-year-old to make to a
Can't see why anyone would break up with you, to be honest. I
got to pause there and just say that's what is that what how
does that mean anything?
That's like a little Yeah, I don't know. This is a very weird
statement for a 31-year-old to make to a 20-year-old. Uh-oh.
What would they different for him to like give him a list of
all the reasons why people should break up with him? Like what
is the alternative be like yeah sh would have broken up for you
too like what is the
concept
Thor would use pet names to establish a sense of intimacy and
attachment. He would also use them to praise Lyric's submission.
I bet he calls her fat.
That's a good infatuated woof. Oo woo. Spoiled by this little
woof. No. Can we stop doing oo? Good boy. I I hate when you say
it.
Oh. Whoa.
Little pet woof.
You like being my good little pup, don't you? Up.
Turn his head up and kisses you softly. My wolf.
Of course. Thanks, babe. Starting now, babe. Oh, woo.
Flops down on stomach with his arms up. Whatever you like, babe.
Yeah, this guy is clearly clearly a furry. Kelly, I'm sorry.
It's over. It's over for this guy. This is I mean, the furry
part is not the problem. It's whether they're I was concerned
about. Okay. They're not This is just cringe. I
They are clearly a furry. My god.
Okay.
Am I still in Hold on. Is this still working?
Yeah, but you're in the one under training. I'm not moving any
goalposts. I said if you don't fully commit and wear a fursuit,
you're not really a furry.
You're like a non-committal furry.
Training submission. Thor will often compliment Lyric for their
submission and reward them with praise for agreeing with him.
Sounds to me like you like the idea of being a submissive pet.
Oo.
The only new guy comes out with bangers like very rarely, but
today is one of them. This is exactly what collectivist communist
conservative furries like Celebration Station Celebration Salvation
say and do. I don't think that's their name, but I know what
they mean. Is it C
or Celebration something? I don't know. But true.
Sorry, I'm going to stop interrupting now. My bad.
Sounds to me you like the idea of being submissive pet. The wo
uh only sometimes.
Slips up floor once a caller loves my
Who will
I really want to be yours forever?
At once.
Oh boy. You're fine. Always a shy doggo.
Ew. Sometimes it feels like you're interested in being a pet
more than a partner. Is that the case?
What? No. No. Not really.
Devoted. What?
Nod nod nod
yours. Oo.
Oh. Oh, is the voice cutting out for you
Yeah.
Hold on. Is the voice cutting out? Oh, okay. Hold on. I'll do
it closer. I'll make it better. Hold on.
Oh, this is also peeking pretty bad. We should be good now.
This is like insanely high level voice changing, but okay.
Okay. Hold on. All right. Uh, devoted
No, I already read that part.
You really want to be mine no matter what, huh?
Well, not no matter what.
Thor really looks forward to meeting Lyric, expressing his excitement,
even counting down the days until they meet.
I'm going to have a lot of fun with you at TwitchCon.
Devilish issue woo.
Cuddling is also on my list if we have time for that.
I call big spoon another devilish woo.
Uh, okay. How unfortunate it would be if some innocent cuddles
turned into something more.
Super wanted
15 days.
Five days.
Did they not talk for 10 days?
I don't I guess not. I guess that was like Yeah. 15 days, 5 days.
Jesus.
In this passage, Thor brings up the topic of moving. suggests
that L to uh suggests that L move close to him. Reinforces the
idea of moving closer with a state of fact detached from his
own desire. States that it is explicitly L's idea to move in
with him. Praises L's intelligence after they agree with the
idea.
Also, do you live on your own?
And I just feel like things are out of my control.
Hey, how will you disappoint me?
Soon I will.
Yeah, the end of the semester. That's when I turn 21 and my mom
wants me out.
Will you be moving?
Probably have to move close to my school for the time being since
I'm also taking spring there.
Okay,
not a school. My god,
this person's not in high school. Please
kill myself. 21-year-old high schooler that he would be
he would be batting. Well, I found out today that a that men
are really into women with Down syndrome.
So, that's one reason they would still be in high school. Oh,
no. Have you seen the filters? You seen the filters? Oh,
nobody has any innocence anymore. You know, picked depraved.
Okay, pulling back. In this conversation, Thor notices that I've
been distant distant. I express my insecurities about my adequacy.
Uh, some messages may be omitted from this excerpt. Best efforts
were made to maintain all necessary context. Please refer to
the transcript or archive for the full version.
What?
Where's the transcript or archives?
You missed some. I miss Where did I miss some? The chat had a
scroll. Wait, what?
What do you Oh. Oh [__]
Whoops. Yeah, I did not see that. My bad. My bad. My bad.
Okay, hold on.
So, still up.
Why do you ask?
It would be nice to have you get closer.
What city are you in?
Oh, so the
huh? I'm assum I'm supposed to sound like a dick.
I was thinking I could go to Calpali if they accepted me.
It's 5 minutes apart here due to the
Make sure you speak into the microphone at like a normal volume.
Don't be too dramatic because I think that clips it
Okay.
It's a little closer. Everything is 5 minutes apart here due
to freeways.
It's a little close. Oh, it's at least a little closer. It's
actually right between us right now in terms of travel
Oh, where is Cal Poly?
4 hours from you and me.
Okay. No, this clip's the beginning of everything that you say,
dude. I'll just do it without the voice. The voice is not really
that required, guys. Come on. Come on.
I can do the voice. I can I can make this work with just my voice.
Okay. It's not quite the same, but it's almost there.
No, the voice is working, but every time he starts speaking,
it clips the beginning of what he's saying.
Uh, yeah, it would make vis and also make future moving easier
if things work out between us. But also, Calpolly is hard to
get into.
You seem pretty set on moving in with
Well, yeah, I suppose so.
No, your wish. I'm not going to do this. Stop. Okay. Okay. Quick
woof.
I'm gonna have to do it myself. So,
it's fine.
I don't know what's going on with it, but I'm just planning out
for now.
Every time you talk for a while, it's fine, but then you stop
talking and then it's like a and I can't hear anything that you're
saying. Okay. Yeah, I can figure it out after.
Anyway, uh I'm just
I'm just planning out for now. I like to think ahead.
Do what gives me the most options now is that I can make an easier
or make easier choices in the future.
Did you even say you're lying? I didn't hear anything.
Oh, hold on. Oh.
Uh, they're not. I see.
Uh, you guys are hearing the voice changer in the Discord still
because um I had to switch it over manually, but it's fine. On
the stream, they heard it correctly. I went, "Okay."
Yeah. Okay. We're off of the voice changer entirely now. Okay.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, I'll switch the thing back over here, too. Good. We're
good. We're good. We're good.
Honestly, this will just be better. Some messages may be omitted
from this excerpt, and apparently in the full archive, there
might be more. Okay, cool. You seem to have pulled back a
School's been really beating me up, to be honest.
Well, I'll try harder for you. You just seemed so interested
and then suddenly not.
Oh, sorry.
I really don't know what to say to that except that I've been
a lot busier. But also, I don't think I would really end up being
enough for you as a mate. So, I have kind of backed off in that
regard. Though, that doesn't change the fact that I want to spend
more time with you still.
Mate, totally furries. Mate, totally fries. Mate, totally furries.
100% fries. A furry term. That's definitely a furry term. 100%.
Uh, because they're because that's what you call animals partners,
mates.
I didn't know that.
Okay. Well, most people know that. You want to say to us?
Uh, I have
nothing to say. No, I don't find this hot at all.
Yep. Keep in mind at this point in time, oh, I mentioned that
I've been role playing with another person. Keep in mind that
at this point in time, Thor is married to his wife and also has
a committed relationship with Sheay and also lives with both
of them. Thor will fixate on the fact that L role played with
his friend. In this conversation, Thor conflates role playing
with real life and accuses L of cheating on him. Thor will later
weaponize his this admission to impose guilt on Lyric. In not
taking no for an answer, Thor says close friends aren't real.
Okay, bro. This is like cited so it's it's so goofy actually.
But like by the way, I'm I'm I'm basically on the page of like
I am not taking any of this seriously. Like the way they're the
way they're like overdescribing things making me feel very goofy.
That's the vibe I have so far. Okay. So, we can just have fun
with it. Anyway, role playing.
Oh, also both of them would be none of them. It's basically saying
it it's only cheating if it's um real life, which is probably
actually the wrong position for this person to have. Whatever.
Anyway, so are you really not that interested? I felt like maybe
you found someone else or something.
Yes, I'm interested. I'm sorry. Sorry I haven't been super active
lately, but it's just because school's been kicking my ass.
Are you Oh, and you didn't find anyone else? H
to be honest. I've been flirting around, but no, not really found
anyone else.
Flirting around?
Yeah. Oo.
What you mean?
Like um Herp.
That's ERP, by the way. Erotic role play.
That was an animal sound. Okay.
are there not more? There should be like way more role playinging
messages, right? I'm pretty confident. Oh, no. The shaming is
a part of the role playing stuff
for further reading on shame is a tool for abuse. See the article
on shame.
Aides shame.
Oh, boy. Okay. Thor shames Lyric for roleplaying, treating them
like filth and accusing them of cheating on him.
You ignored my advances and erped with other dudes. Not much
else to say there. To be real, this is [__] up. Like,
I have no idea if you even realize how up it is to me. We even
have plans to meet up IRL in like a month. This is the reason
I don't date people. Can't you can't stop yourself from around
for 5 minutes. I was literally here every night trying to get
affection from you while you were somebody else. Yeah, it is
how it is. You replied to me when you could. But you have time
to ERP with
I don't know how many others you think there were, but there
was one. And I I don't think you know how many times I did it.
And it was two.
Neat. Mine's zero and zero because I told you I was into you
and had mutual plans with you to express that in person. Pro
tip foundations don't include other people. I super don't trust
you after this little side quest. So what do you want? Like no
like I don't trust you. You did something really messed up here.
You could have just come to me any time and been like yo I'm
turned on right now.
It was when you were asleep. To be fair, our sleep schedules
don't exactly align.
Who gives a if I was asleep? Sorry, I someone else, but you were
asleep at the time. So,
after conflating with real life, role playing with real life,
Thor accuses Lyric of cheating. No, right now I'm super not.
You broke my trust and showed me
you could easily just cheat on me on a whim. Messages accusation.
Well,
I know it's no excuse, [__] but I was still under
the impression that you weren't interested.
No, that's um that's pretty uncool, especially since you were
giving me the cold shoulder every time I tried to get anything
going. Wow. Really did not expect that.
I'm sorry. I seriously didn't mean to blow you off or anything,
so to speak.
You ignored my advances and erped with other dudes. Not much
else to say there.
Yeah, but I wasn't trying to ignore you. And I'm sorry if it
came off that way.
To be real, this is up. Like I have no idea if you even realize
how up it is to
I don't know. Like I said, I didn't even know if you were interested
until recently. It's still not an excuse. I'm
Except I said I was the whole time while literally trying to
text you.
Text [__] you. While literally trying to text you
while you ignored me and apparently went out with other guys,
went after other guys. What the dude? We even have plans to meet
up IRL in like a month. What the hell?
No, hold on. Cuz Riyle just like him in chat said he's victim
in the sheets, too.
Oh, that's so real.
I need water. My voice is dying. Hold on.
Victim in the streets and victim in the sheets. That's crazy.
How are you feeling about meeting this
Um, I'm just glad he's not a I can deal with a cringe furry.
I probably interacted with like dozens of cringe
Not, you know, I'm being around though.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, I'm trying to think when
Oh, sorry. I was I was thinking of a point. We didn't finish
reading. Just we didn't. But, um, I just wanted to make a point
that Kelly was saying like, "Is this guy really a furry?" And
literally every term he's used this entire time has been basically
talking about what you uh has been like using animals. I get
it. I get it. I get it. I have to go soon. That's why I'm saying,
"Can we finish reading?" Yes. Yes. Sorry. Sorry. I just needed
to uh set this up really quick. I know. I know. Sorry. There
we go. I still want to go.
Oh, okay. All right.
You don't seem to be getting it. Do you not understand?
I do understand. I just don't know what to say except I'm sorry.
What do you understand then?
Thor, if I had known you were like seriously into me, I would
not have done it. Trust me. And I understand that you feel led
on and that I abandoned you without telling you.
This is the reason I don't date people. Can't stop yourself from
What the hell is that?
What?
What is fat Kelly?
Oh,
that is wrong. My head is gigantic. Also, I don't like this because
it feels like engaging in someone's fetish and I don't like that.
I don't know whose footage this is,
but uh why does my face get so wide when it speaks? It's like
a frog.
It doesn't even look like Kelly.
Uh as it doesn't. No, it doesn't look anything like Kelly.
The weird thing is Top has made a fat JTO yet. Can I get a fat
JTO already? I'm feeling left out over here.
Yeah. Isn't that
a weird thing? What? Can we get a skinny EJ
Okay. All right. These people. All right. Um, where are we? Okay.
Okay.
Okay. This is the reason I don't Oh, I need to do the voice.
Hold on. Why is he saying you don't date people if you marry
them? Are you turn
what? Okay. I I didn't know what you were doing. You're just
taking I need to get in the mood to do the voice. This is the
reason I don't date people. Can't stop yourself from around for
five minutes. I was literally here every night trying to get
some affection from you while you were somebody else sakes. What
an absolute thing to do.
Thor, that's seriously not how it is. I replied to you when I
could. Seriously, I did. Yeah, it is how it is. You replied to
me when you could, but you had time to ERP with other dudes.
You think I'm a [__] or something? Come the
I don't know how many others you think there were, but there
was one. And I don't think you know how many times I did it.
It was and it was two. Not like that changes the circumstances
a lot, but I think you're blowing this out of proportion.
Neat. Mine's zero and zero because I told you that I was into
you and had mutual plans to express that in
Did we repeat? Is this looping? We So I think they cut they filtered
a bunch of messages out. Oh, there's Okay, can we just Okay,
I seriously didn't know. Dude, you me like having just met me.
You bought a ticket to TwitchCon to see me, and you didn't know?
You're being
Yes, I I know how I view you, but I didn't know how you viewed
me. Except I told you constantly and showed you affection that
I was interested, but like to take things slow and to build a
foundation. Pro tip, foundations don't include other people.
You're right. And I'm sorry.
And the last week or two, you stopped being affectionate back.
Suddenly had no time for me. And now you tell me you were erping
with other dudes. Not like I needed any more of a hint than that.
I'm not trying to throw you any hints. If I stop being affectionate,
I'm sorry. I never meant to stop that. Me not having time for
you was
simple because I just didn't have time. I have a lot of deadlines
to work around.
Clearly had enough time for someone else. Hope it was worth it.
If you watch when I'm on Telegram, you'd know that anytime I'm
online, I reply to you. if you said something and no it wasn't
worth it because I said I'm sorry and I do regret it.
I don't expect forgiveness but at least understanding.
There's no time at all that I had for someone else but not you.
Clearly there was. You had a time you had time to eat someone
else twice in your own words. Seriously dude in the future if
you have a love interest don't do this stupid. This is mad.
You're right.
Did he link?
You blew it, man.
So,
and like I said, I'm sorry and don't expect forgiveness. And
I hope we can still be friends.
Even Ice King knows you up. I super don't trust you after this
little side quest. So, what do you want? Who the is Ice King
to be friends? The guy from whatever we just watched the video.
I like being around you. Oo.
No, like I don't trust you. You did something really messed up
here and it was super needless. Like really absurd.
I regret it. I seriously do. It was not worth it.
You could have just come to me any time and been like, "Yo, I'm
turned on right now." like, you know, we just did on voice recently.
But hey, man, text another bloke must uh text another bloke must
have just been so enticing, right?
It was when you were asleep. To be fair, our sleep schedules
don't exactly align.
Who gives a if I was asleep? Who gives a if I was asleep? Sorry,
I someone else. You were asleep at the time. So
Yeah. Yeah.
Bro, in my in my condo, I'm like on the first floor, right? Uh
well, it's only two floors, but there's like in front of my place
is a big grassy area and um there's kids playing out there and
I can hear them playing out there and I know they must be able
if I can hear them, they must be able to hear me. So, I'm sorry
to those that's up, but you know, I pay for this place and this
is my job. So, you guys
I can't see them. My blinds are closed. Your job is your being
as a furry.
Uh yeah, my job is fluid, Kelly. And sometimes that's what it
is.
Yeah, that's how it is.
That is how it is. Uggh. You know what? I was looking forward
to when you got back and we talked out spending the day with
your ass. Now I can't. Why the Why the honest did you do this?
I'm sorry.
Sorry. I'm sorry isn't an answer, dude. What the was the reason?
Was it like a longtime friend or some [__]
Yes, but that's no excuse. Did you lavish them in love you love
you and let's meet ups like you did with me? And further and
further was this even online? Well,
no, I didn't lavish them up. And yes, it was online.
I'm typing a last minute lab report right now, so please excuse
any
Man, your lab report. This is Do you know them? IRL 2.
No, I don't. Then why?
They're across the country. Because I wasn't looking for love
from them. It was just an impulse, and I'm sorry that I acted
on it. Well, what now?
Oh, how can I be sure you wouldn't do this again?
Because now I know you're interested. And yes, I should have
picked up on that, but I really didn't. And I'm sorry for that.
No, right now I'm super not. You broke my trust and showed me
you could easily just cheat on me on a whim.
Uh, damn. Kenny, can Kenny get in Discord and take my place?
Yeah, I can do both sides. I can do both sides or whatever. We'll
figure it out. Thanks for coming on, Jan.
Okay, bye guys. See
Where's the leave button?
The following transcript has incomplete annotations and not all
hostile behavior hostile behaviors will fall down. This is weird
and I'm the only one that's fat as well. Are you going to read
messages with me or are you going to Is this a hostage situation
now? I'm asking if you're going to read messages. I'm not AFK.
You'll participate in the stream, Kelly. I'm not
participating. Okay. I'm not being like negotiated with. I'll
just leave.
Okay. Change it.
Are you reading?
No.
Get literally anybody else in here.
Okay. I don't want to ERP as a furry.
It's uh it's like a whole thing
and having that like immortalized forever, but I'm not doing
it. Uhhuh.
That Okay.
All right. Um, hold on.
There you go. Someone said they'll do it in chat. Bring them
in.
Uh, it's going to be have to be somebody I know.
Why? You got extreme dad in this Discord. Just give them that
role.
Uh, no. It's going to have to be somebody I know.
But I'm I'm checking the main Discord. You can only furry ERP
with someone you
Uh, no. I just want somebody who's going to come and raid that
I know.
10 five gifted. Let's go. They've got the qualifications to be
as a furry.
Okay. Uh I'm just I guess I'm just reading. Is this like all
the same stuff
Oh god, why did we start?
Oh, why why did they do this? Why why wouldn't they just Okay,
never mind. Now we know for the rest of these we read the full
transcript.
Uh what day is it today? It is Monday.
Uh okay.
Oh, look. Extreme Jad
the waiting room.
Uh, yeah, I'm good.
You don't want Extreme Dad to ERP with you as a furry? Nope.
Avatar's gone. Okay, the people want it. I'm just saying
what's wrong with you people?
He left.
Oh boy.
That would have been content
would have proved he can read.
That would have been the most surprising thing of all of this.
Uhhuh.
Why are you silent and just not what are you okay?
Oh, I'm good. I'm just waiting to see if Kelly will uh want to
participate in the stream at some point. I'm going to the bathroom.
I'll be right back. Not reading. I'm not erping as a furry freak.
I don't get paid. Why would I do that for free
or at all? I don't know what kind of price I would charge for
this. I think it's out of his budget.
I promise I will not do anything but
What else would you do?
And now I'm concerned that you were considering other things.
What are those
That's terrifying.
It's going to add lip.
He's just going to add in his own spice to the fairy peeing.
Oh boy. Like I would invite any of you like leaving this until
Cherry comes back uh in a couple days. There's not a single other
person you trust to read.
I trust lots of people to read, but I will just go do like my
own thing. This is like the content. If you want if you want
to join the Discord and you don't want to participate in the
content, uh you don't know why you don't want to laughing in
the background until Cherry left and now I'm suddenly not participating.
But somebody laughing in the background, right? I don't I don't
need somebody laughing in the background. There's other people
offering to do it. You asked me to come join this Discord so
you could be on the screen and say you don't actually
want to participate for some arbitrary reason that you've not
explained.
Uh the reason is you asked us to come join this Discord, right?
And then you don't want to participate. You don't want to like
be a part of this. Yes, I am participating. I'm just not reading
the furry ERP out.
Okay. That's what the content is. You're complaining that I'm
not doing the one thing
the thing that is stated when I came in here I was not going
to do I'm complaining that you're not doing the thing that is
the content. So I had a boundary which is I don't want a furry
ERP and now you're okay then why did you ask to join the stream
while the furry ERP is happening? Because I have been engaging
I just haven't been erping dung devil donated $5. This would
be sorry but some of us have high standards. We don't want like
the internet immortalizing us reading out furry ERP. Okay. You
might not have any standards for us. No.
No. I didn't say it's not okay. People that call themselves a
furry and they're not willing to wear a suit is just halfassing
it. It's just like it's just like Yeah, I don't know how to explain.
I'm going to the other Discord because people are there. Okay.
You are such a misery. Okay, fine. Well, that's where other people
are who can join. So, you could invite them here and you won't
for some reason
because it would only be to help you and you won't help me by
participating in the stream. I am participating. I just don't
want a furry ERP and I've explained that. That's what the cont
I've explained to you. That's what the content is. You can just
go while this is happening. You can just go while this is happening
software and whatever this lyric guy is. That is the
and sit and chat.
I think that you have no respect for any of the requests that
I make and it's not many. And that's that I don't want a furry
ERP on a stream. But you could invite other people here.
Uh I could.
Yes. So just to
weren't reading. This is not me. You even had extreme
offering to read which would have been hilarious and you're like
you want to join and then not be a part of it at all that we
joined this for you. You're defining not being you brought up
a different story that was un unattached to this. Okay. You brought
a different story.
Oh god. You're defining not
wanting a furry er and I just actually don't need to I don't
need to do that. I can just go and run the stream
I mean, you're just like, this is just not true because I am
willing to engage with it. I just don't want to read out furry
ERP. Yeah, but people are here to watch. Kenny has joined.
Yeah, that's okay. Kenny might do it. Would Kenny do it? I don't
know.
I don't really The point is I don't really make I don't do erping
stuff like this. I don't know what you think it is. I do I do
cosplay luds. I'm not doing hardcore and like taking dick. Where
is the hardcore?
Uh I'm saying I don't do this stuff either. I don't
where where have they even talked about where have they done
anything?
I'm responding to a chatter. Sorry. Where have they done anything
explicitly on these DMs? Uh it's very cringy and it's talking
about stuff. I don't care. I don't want to engage with that.
That's
Uh there's just so we're clear, there's nothing like explicitly
in these DMs. Uh that's your opinion. I uh disagree.
Mhm.
Stop trying to gaslight me. Two people have offered and join
the waiting room and you're like, "No, I need Kelly to do it."
And you haven't explained why and it's becoming progressively
more Thank you for joining the stream, Kelly. I'm going to go
do this over here and yeah, Kenny can hop in. I'll do it with
Kenny. Okay, have a good night.
But Kenny,
I'm like I was just dude like actually drags away from the segments
consistently, right? Like always wants to change the subject
and then sits here and like doesn't want to actually read. Just
read the DMs. Just put the DMs in the bag, bro.
Oh, see there's the there's I drink bleach. Tell her to leave.
I didn't tell her to leave. I left cuz I'm annoyed. Hello, Kenny.
How are you?
Oh god. You know, Kelly forced me to do this. Kelly has a gun
to my head. Has a gun to your head. Well, honestly, this is the
role playing part. I think we're like through this part. Although,
I'm now I'm annoyed because for this section, he had the whole
transcript part. And now he had three different versions. He
had one version where he cut it down a whole bunch. He has another
version where he cut it down a little bit. And then he has this
version where he doesn't cut anything out. And it's like I just
wanted the version where he didn't cut anything out. Look, he
sent pictures of animals and
Yeah, it's formatted badly.
All I wanted was the full the full. That's all I wanted.
I would have let Kelly opt out of any by the way. Absolutely.
But almost all of this is notable.
She's like faking a boundary and saying it's a boundary so that
she like doesn't have to do anything. She can sit here and do
nothing and just attract all the
So, unfortunately,
I've said I've set a boundary where I don't want people who come
on stream just to disrupt.
It's actually not something I want. Space Ghost, thanks for the
gifted sub. I appreciate it.
Yeah, I I don't know. It's like
Maybe she wanted to keep the software
Uh, possibly. Okay. I Are we committing to this whole thing,
Kenny? Are we committing to the whole thing? Cuz hold on, let
me let me see what the next section is. Let me see if those ones
No means yes. Is there going to be a transcript at the bottom?
Annotated transcript.
This will be the whole thing for all of these DMs. I guess
this is like the worst format cuz I want to know if I'm missing
anything important up here, but I also want to just do the DMs.
No. If I'm dead in the street tomorrow, it's your fault.
You Kenny dead in the street. Yeah. Kelly Jean's coming for you.
No. I mean, people kind of make fun of me for eating.
It's just too It's just too funny.
I I'm sorry, but like this happens quite regularly where like
I'm I'm trying to do segments specifically for YouTube like uh
so that somebody could take my stuff and it's like incentivizing
people to take my stuff. I want more people posting my stuff
on YouTube. So, I'm trying to make them like almost like their
YouTube segments so that other people so it's not just one channel
that's posting my stuff, right? And then like she comes in and
she just switches the topic. She doesn't do any work pre pre-stream
or anything. And it's like it's fine, but it's not just Kelly's
stream to come in and do whatever she wants. That's not what
it is.
But that's how she treats it. So,
it was like it was almost like I joined that other Discord for
a reason today.
Why would anything work? Because the thing the stream is literally
we do the things that are a part of the topic. That's what we
do. We like split it up. That's always been what it is. Why is
she pretending she doesn't understand what the stream is and
always has been.
Anyway, okay. We're going back to
Kelly's equity in your stream. She kind of does, but like at
some point it's it's like, "Bro, what are you doing?"
You're replying it's not okay if I don't want to do one specific
thing. Actually, Kelly, you're just lying now because I told
you that I would let you opt out of explicitly DMs.
You just didn't want to read it at all.
is all of it. No, it isn't.
She's not pretending. She doesn't know. She's just an You know
this. We know this. Everyone has said this since you started.
Wow.
The line is I don't get paid to be here, so I'm not doing I don't
want to do. Yeah, that's totally fine. But then don't ask me
to come do the the to be in that Discord to be in a different
Discord that's not my Discord where not everybody is
or you so you can like sit in the background and just lob grenades
at the coverage is goofy.
Uh, how am I being an [__] Because I don't want to
read weird furry DMs, Kelly asks. Uh, Kelly, you've already said
multiple times you don't actually believe she's a furry or that
either of these people are furries. You said that multiple times.
They don't get the fursuits. They're not actually furries.
I'm telling yachties to come read.
Why isn't Wolf Gand here reading this? He's the resident. Dude,
I
Oh, hold on. I would actually like do a private call with Wolf
Gand if he'd do it right now.
I don't think he will. And he's probably not around.
I would totally do that right now.
Yeah, I'm crying, Kelly. How dare you do this to me? I I'd totally
add Kenny to that call.
We could take turns.
Wait, pause. Rotation. He did. He did not He did not mean that
we were We will not be taking turns.
What is this?
Hello, Jy Boo. I hope you're happy. I got it turned out for just
trying to get where Yog did on my birthday. And you? You didn't
even come to save me. They even tried to pin you to control me,
but you No, what?
You just let me suffer.
So, yeah, I'm Mattis was like made for this role, wasn't she?
What is
Why is she delaying? Why is she Hold on. I didn't finish it.
I'm breaking up with you. I need a new boyfriend who will fight
with Okay.
Uh, was this a specifically an audition tape or